okay so we are here with the polemicist
and satirist Sam Rafi welcome thanks Tim
um I'm really interested in generative
art it's something which has taken over
the entire AI landscape over the last
year or so we've had models like stable
diffusion and mid-journey and now
everyone and their dog is generating art
because all you need to do is prompt it
and there is a bit of a science to the
prompting technique so you can say
Unreal Engine or volumetric lighting or
you know you can put an artist's name in
there sure and it generates you a
coherent beautiful piece of art but
there's more to Art than Aesthetics
isn't there
um
yes
it's like the the value or meaning of
art yeah and the funny thing about it is
to say does generative art have value
say or meaning
doesn't really ask any different
questions of what is the meaning of art
or what is art because however it has it
has an effect on the world doesn't it
generative art you can make it someone
can see it like it or hate it hmm that's
changed the world ever so slightly so it
has that value isn't it yeah it has an
effect on the world but art must be more
than that just simple effect
I mean what exactly defines the value of
odd
I don't think that's a that's one of
those demand that's one of those
questions that can't be actually
answered I would say
um I do think it's got to refer to
something which is like I said more than
an effect on the world so what I'm
getting at is that if it to be artistic
it's probably got to refer to something
that's
like subsuming or crystallizing the
unintelligible do you know what I mean
or or even even referring back like a
like uh what do I write here like a
fireworks of remembrance I put in this
respects allusions to like the innate
reasoning mechanisms that in present our
day archetypes to our human survival I
mean why are we attracted to certain
things why are we artistically uh
aroused or or rather artistically pulled
drawn to certain things and what are
where's the value there now I don't
think we can if we talk about value or
meaning is that that's Beyond
like physical then then what then what
we're talking about really you know has
it got to have allusion to something
mystical or magical or almost Godlike or
infinite you know to to be our is that
what you'd say well well you raised
something interesting there which I
think we'll get to later which is this
um uh two substances so there's this
idea held by scientists now that the
physical world has what they call causal
closure which means everything that
exists is explainable and by things in
the physical world yes and you're
alluding to there that there might be
some pointer within art to what is in
the non-physical world but just before
we get there I mean I think it's
interesting to decompose art
um not only into the obvious box which
is the Aesthetics but you were touching
on something interesting which is the
intention and mental state subjective
experience of the artist so it's almost
as if the artist is trying to capture
um non-linguistically using the brush
Strokes using whatever the medium is
something which alludes to their mental
state and yes absolutely and you might
then say well if the person receiving
the art or should we say viewing the art
and enjoying the art do they have does
their experience have any relation to
the experience of the artist who created
it I might be sure that's important
necessarily why well I mean overlap how
would you how do we end how could we
reduce that to find a how can we reduce
that conversation to actually decide
whether it overlaps anyway
in the end it's just an effect it has on
you I think the art but say I as say me
as the viewer take me as the Observer of
the art I might get an artistic
um part of my artistic uh aesthetic
because what I enjoy about art might be
that somebody
another human being out there has
constructed that and they constructed it
they said with their with their brush
Strokes with their intuition with their
creativity with any of these human
aspects and maybe knowing that it's not
from another human being means that
part of part of what I wanted from the
art is gone
but then I'd have to know that in
advance so if I didn't know that he
wasn't say you gave me something that
looked like it could have been done by a
human easily and I got then you said to
me afterwards Sam you've said all this
and then I've said that but that was
created by a uh generative model
yes yes but but it might be reductionist
because with language it makes sense to
talk about it as a form of compression
so what you do is is you take an
intention and um and the reason we talk
about semantics is because there is a
bifurcation there's the form of language
which is the syntax and then there's the
meaning which is the semantics and and
the idea is that the meaning can be
reconstructed by the person and it must
be deducible not only from the form of
the language the words that I say but
also the World Knowledge I have and
reasoning ability and and so on but it
might be overly reductionist to think of
art as just being a form of compressed
communication
um because there's more to it than that
it's almost as if you were saying before
that the artist knows it's a form of
compressed communication and you're
almost reflexively compensating for that
Communication channel
yeah explain what you mean by that so um
should should art be a form of
persuasion so it could be something that
you don't necessarily expect the
consumer to understand what you meant
what you're doing is you're delivering a
payload which will have pressure in a
certain direction which you have some
vague control over okay
the question of what hmm
you know has it gone from that one Tim
that's okay the question of like say
does the art have have a value
if it's just created by a by a set of
code
does it have like a uh is it the same
well
we could go there a little bit because
you could argue
that there is still an intention there
yeah so the person who created the art
yeah
constructed a prompt they had an
intention they had a context right there
is statistics yes yes and and also
there's there's another interesting
attribute which is the people who create
generative art it's not one shot
they iterate they say I'm going to
generate 10 pieces and I'm going to
choose that one and I'm going to choose
that one and I like those two pieces so
I'm going to create another piece which
derives from those two rights okay and
I'm gonna I'm gonna take the yellow dog
second generation with an orange dog and
it feels like the more interaction there
is with the process the more the artists
can both claim to have
um created the art because part of this
is about or you don't need skills to
make art anymore but but also there is a
stronger intentionality behind the art
yeah and it's like this well you do do
still need skills to create the art but
the skills changed if you're just doing
it through prompts but the skill
potentially is far less potentially you
know you can create quite an interesting
piece of art with just a few prompts
because somebody's created the AI to do
so well what is the value of skill in
art
well again let's put it this way do you
use when you find watching somebody do
something extremely skillful
juggling 11 uh bowling what they call it
bowling pins or something on a unicycle
smoking a pipe yeah does this do you
think wow brilliant or that not does not
interest you at all no it does interest
me and it does because it's scarce right
okay so we already do we already have we
can accept a fascination of skillful
people and go back to Rembrandt remember
we did our photography Rembrandt Van
Dyke a few of these sort of rembrand was
born in 1603 I think so it's not like
the 17th century or the late
um Century before that is Renaissance
um painters there's skill Not only was
mesmerizing to us now to us nowadays it
had much more pragmatic effect then
because obviously you know back in that
time you hit 38 in your big estate you
think well I'm probably gonna die very
soon of some disgusting disease with our
teeth right now so I bet somebody better
immortalize me soon next to my uh next
to my grandfather was on the wall
um obviously now because we have
pictures we don't rely on artists like
that in the same way anymore but we look
back at say Rembrandt and we admire or I
do personally again is I'm speaking on
the Wii but I'm more than happy that
this is not the case we admire how on
Earth with a brush with with um with
paint and with glazes and with and with
very little knowledge the Flemish the
Flemish method was all about there about
there really did he create something
that looks so vibrantly real and seems
to convey something beyond the the
realness so what I'm saying is Rembrandt
was known to create
um a stylized painting so very accurate
but he sometimes he'd be in a in a shade
or one of his eyes would be slightly
different and it was always to have this
sort of like effect that he was looking
into you or that he he couldn't look at
himself in that portrait so there was
like a bundle of information being given
there
um but the skill
I'm actually I would I look at him
specifically uh I think how did he
achieve that
um how did he achieve that with with
such a with such with what you and me
have this is the difference isn't it we
both have hands we have access to brush
we have access to paint but he did
something with his skill level which is
now does that give it does that give it
a value in you additional value is that
a separate part of the value of a piece
of art in your mind um it is it is and
it's a value which has now been
attenuated and eroded because now
anybody can create art like this I
myself was enamored with air
um I've got it on the walls I was
obsessed with it at the beginning I was
generating lots of art pieces and the
models are significantly better than
that now you kind of you can generate
photorealistic model it's actually quite
an interesting new space that we're
coming into you can photo realistic art
wow so art which is you know not of the
real world that we live in but still
with photorealistic qualities which is
quite interesting you know when you're
someone paints like not even maybe
perhaps an app not an abstract piece but
what we call impressionist piece are you
familiar with someone like um bacon
Francis Bacon or or
um well I was going to bring that in yes
because
um you were you were talking to the
representational aspect of Art and then
we can diverge into representing what
representing the world or representing
the mind yeah or both and when you are
representing the mind that sort of leads
into the impressionist artist and that's
on because that they're actually talking
about whether they're capturing an
abstract space which is not necessarily
grounded in the room yeah because I
suppose it would be also would be more
talking about the expressionists and the
surrealists because of the
Impressionists we're talking more about
the monarium Monet and Manet although
they did things like that I'm talking
more I suppose that you know like when
you paint someone and it's complete
Guernica by Picasso you know you've seen
the massive Guernica which is like about
war isn't it and all these sorts of uh
Illusions to face with facial shape but
they're they're mutated yes and he's
done it they're mutated and he thinks
he's expressing the mutation
of what pain rage mixed in with a face
and that's this is this is the this is
what he can see and how he can reflect
represent all that like by by
experiencing that in him and then that's
how his skill gets his ability to paint
he gets um commandeered by what he's
trying to convey yes is that something
unique to human that's that's that's
that's that's another question well in a
sense it is because we talk about the
Picasso problem in computer vision
architectures which is that when you
take a face and you rearrange it we
still see it as a face because it has an
abstract understanding of what is
interesting and uh model is up until now
some of them can recognize components
like they have this whole part
relationship and they have what we call
it so you can teach them to to look for
elements of even if it's not in the
correct configuration that's exactly
right so every machine learning
algorithm has these inductive priors and
it's just a trick to reduce the space of
possible things you can learn so in in
this particular case the priors would be
learning tropical translational symmetry
which means that you can recognize an
eye even if it's not in the right place
globally because it's focusing on local
information not Global Information yeah
okay interesting uh and so go back to it
what I said so going from the all of the
other skill aspects so we've got the
skill and then we've got what you might
be trying to convey beyond the straight
skill yeah can a generative model
convey something unique
or can it just create something unique
that is the million dollar question yeah
to what extent are they creative and
cynically to what extent are we creating
um critics of these AI models say that
they don't have the ability to form
abstractions and when you look at them
it's quite difficult to distinguish
we'll get into the whole mimicry thing
later but
um the appearance of forming
abstractions can be quite seductive so
there's always this question of well is
it really is it really doing the
abstractions let me say it's you mean by
computers particularly or humans as well
um well both are I mean I guess we can
accept that humans can form abstractions
because at least that's the thing we've
created the definition from Human doing
it is what we come up with the term
abstractions because humans do it so in
some respects it's got that definitional
um correctness that's right but it's
such a loaded term because when you
speak to neuroscientists they say that
there's no bright line in the ability to
create abstractions they just say you
look at the brain it's abstractions all
the way down every single Processing
Unit in the brain in the visual system
you're just kind of like learning these
increasingly complex hierarchies of
information and you can think of the
entire trajectory as being a line of
abstraction so Consciousness would
therefore that be that would do
um well that I would say that's
that's a very deep philosophical point
some people say that Consciousness is
above Dynamics right so and traumas says
that it's a weird phenomenon because it
doesn't have causal power over the rest
of the system it's like a it's like an
Epi phenomenon so you have all of these
Dynamics in the brain right and the
Dynamics are this kind of reflexivity
the self-monitoring and that happens
over successive layers of complexity and
then you get the reflectivity is like
the you get a result from something as
it were and you feed it back into the
feed it back into the formula or the
algorithm yeah okay okay yeah and that's
how so that's how that's how we will
become more sure of the world
well it's it's anyone's guess what the
purpose of Consciousness is and and even
even then you can say well again purpose
very difficult questions to get involved
there isn't it yeah going into TV loss
yeah yeah indeed
but let's let's bring it back to Art
just just for a moment so we we've
spoken about the the value of answer I
believe that these generative models
devalue art
um if anything they've made me less
interested in art not more that's a
right that's a wonderful point because
that's exactly how I would I think that
once the immediate notoriety of it's
gone novelty notoriety novelty if it's
gone yeah you then start thinking well
you know we've now just systematized
almost we turned art into into water
we've tried and mixed it with the water
of science yes so now it's very
difficult to now we're just saying it
has an effect on the world again we can
create it you can put it in your house
it can look nicer your neighbor can like
it you can dislike it or vice versa has
an effect on the world but it's got to
have to be art for art to have a
worthwhile definition it's a broad sense
it's got an oh it's got to do more than
that yes in some respects problem with
it is though maybe it is like that if
you know in the 1920s when the word jazz
came about the term Jazz it was almost
like they created this this thing didn't
fit into any other category so it's
called it Jazz yes rather than it having
like a a straight root it's more like
things that came about that were sort of
playing around formality who called it
jazz
that have a relation to something we
can't otherwise describe that we call
that art
yes but one thing that that you were
touching on which is interesting is is
if it has become trivialized because we
say people like Chomsky say that
technology like this makes us lazy and
it sounds definitely the skill yeah well
it sounds like a charge of elitism
because you could just say before people
used to really think about art they used
to interpret it they used to think you
know
what what are what are the what are The
Strokes that weren't made can I read
between the lines and now we've created
this new generation of people who
consume art like they consume Instagram
yeah and it's almost like we are
deliberately truncating their frame of
reference because with the social media
Paradigm you can sort of flick through
your social media feed and see seven
bits of art you liked in a 60 seconds
yes art then because art then because
something that sort of serves us serves
our identity and serves our aesthetic
requirements like like you said like a
cup of coffee or like a like like a uh a
comment on our post yeah I like that
enjoy that enjoy that enjoy that whereas
for me again meaningful R is when it
takes me outside of myself it shows
everything about myself it takes me out
there to do it hence I'm drawn to that
art I don't see it as a uh
self-referential thing that plays me
does that please me in fact I've been to
a um that natural Portrait Gallery the
friend of mine who wasn't interested in
art and I would say should remain so
because his way of judging art was
whether whether he liked
what it done well what would it have
done how do I put that he didn't really
have any appreciation of the skill
particularly he had no appreciation of
great greater or grander motifs yeah and
ideas that might be conveyed through the
art when we got and I don't know if
you've been to the Portrait Gallery but
you can go through it chronologically so
you can sort of go to those sort of you
know slightly flat
medieval plantagenet style King Stephen
of Boi and uh and Henry II they're sort
of like a bit flat and face this is
prior to the Flemish method that came
about in the sort of 15th century so
hence when you start looking at say da
Vinci even da Vinci have United it's
quite flat hmm there is depth and it's
created cleverly but it's not whereas
when you get to the Renaissance painters
of the people Rubens and and
everything's really rounded they've got
the light they use glazes to create real
real um real depth
um I am drawing all this from it yeah
and I'm drawing the skills and then I go
through it I'm going through as I said
chronologically we go through that flat
period that I think wow that's okay but
it almost looks like rudimentary like
infant humans
um art that you get to that I think the
peaked in the 1670 Renaissance period
there was no photography there was uh
unfortunately the the the the the fear
of death disease illness maybe we'll try
harder yeah to raise above the poverty
if possible I mean something like
rembrand didn't come for money but if
you've got a great skill back in them
days you can be patronized by by wealthy
landowners and kings and queens as he
was he didn't die with any money
unfortunately but you know it gives you
a chance to escape a world that isn't
like ours of comfort and convenience so
perhaps that I mean I'm not I'm not even
theorizing that particularly I'm just
I'm I'm there's a correlation maybe the
more than more than a a causation but
definitely that's where I personally
like art it then became interesting it
went for the impressionist period of the
19th century and then we get into what
Modern Art now I don't like all the
blocks of color in the line and say that
that represents Melancholy you know not
a fan of unmade beds and ashtrays as
like a an illusion or as a metaphor for
for the decaying of society I I think
that they're taking the Mickey now I
think they're turning art in itself
there's an expression of self-hatred I
don't like that we can we can go back to
that in a few in a minute if you want
but coming back to the period I was most
interested in is that
um modern period and there were some
really interesting modernist
but not abstract particularly they were
well painted but no longer were we going
for this beautiful realism we were
trying to say and do a bit more and we
got to this point my friend who's not
interested in art but yeah I like that
one
and I remember rightly it was a it was a
it was a I think it was a portrait
someone from behind so you didn't even
see any of the face and it did convey
but what what what what showed me one
thing is how different two people me and
him could view the whole thing of art he
had an absolutely no objective interest
in the skill or anything that the
painting might be doing or saying but
you you said something interesting then
which is your friend liked it and to
what extent should art be recreational
versus having some utility yeah it could
be used for political reasons for
example I don't think there's a should
there is there
well I mean also did you sort of mean
all ought to be because I mean I don't I
don't really believe if art is what art
is I don't think we can place those sort
of rules on it right right but but then
um if you consume art a lot of what
we've been kind of brushing around here
is this concept of ontology and also you
know mostly Aesthetics versus ontology
and ontology is about capturing you know
the the some kind of the statement about
the existence the being of the artist
and this ontological space is infinitely
large so the consumer of the um art when
they interpret the piece can select
trajectories through that space of
ontology that makes sense yeah and
there's no bright line on what partition
scheme should be used to select from
that space of ontology so it could be
something as simple as well this is this
is how you were feeling emotionally at
the time as the artist and this is my
interpretation as as the consumer but it
feels like there's an infinite space of
ontology yeah which maybe is the is the
beauty of Art in itself
um you know maybe that is why it's so so
so
um
so what would you call it I mean it's
like a it's something that's existed as
far as we're aware in human times human
civilization certainly but way before
that I would guess some sort of art
exists yes yes but but then then you get
to this thing about subject of
experience in general so one one way of
thinking about it is there's an
asymmetry between your subject of
experience and my subject absolutely
yeah and also there's a miniature
intersection of your subjective
experience and my subjective experience
most of your subjective experience is I
mean certainly not verbalizable but it's
also not experienceable in the along the
lines of Nagel's bat thought experiments
so you know we can't conceive of what
it's like to be a bat I also can't
conceive of what it is like to be you
and the interesting thing from an AI
point of view is that these models do
capture what appear to be subjective
experiences and also they seem to have
um a kind of theory of mind for example
they can reason about the beliefs and
intentions of others and a lot of um
psychologists have hold their hands up
at this saying no that can't possibly be
true but evidence seems to suggest
otherwise and then there's this thing
that using language we can if we're
clever right like Leo tolstoid right we
can encode subjective mental States into
the form of language and it is
recoverable in some sense probably not
in the same sense so there's a receding
Horizon of subjective experiences which
are communicable generalizable Universal
right things which can be reconstructed
in the mind of another person but as the
Horizon goes out to see the complexity
increases but I think that the first
time yes I agree with what's saying
there that first type of subjectivity is
that the illusion of objectivity
so what I'm saying is say that say that
um say that we all read this chat we
always read a uh a paragraph from
um or maybe a there's a great illusion
he does to this uh this metaphor of the
of the breaking down of Russian Society
after the French invade and
um Russia and he Likens it to a long uh
extended metaphor of a broken beehive
and people some of the work could be
still trying to do stuff even though
there's no Hive anymore and the Queen's
dead and the Queen's left imagine we're
all obviously have a unique
um subjective experience and then we've
got these unique object um subjective
experiences going on then we decided to
converse upon it and we all within the
the language we could employ seem to
agree very accurately this is what it is
is what it's doing this is what it's
saying this is what we get from it these
are some specific bits we like about it
that's better than that bit because oh
Tim I agree actually so he's more
specific
we might then be able to rationally say
well it's still School subjective stuff
but is there are we being almost
um
almost lured into it as like it's it's
as close as we're going to get to
objective that was actually happening in
that book that's why we all agree on it
subjectively yeah um I mean first of all
I will articulate what I think is
objective information so and it all
comes down to this concept of grounding
so when we talk about the Alps it's an
object which exists in the real world
but it's still possible to go and visit
the Alps and have a subjective
experience so so then you get into this
spectrum of information which is
partially objective and partially
okay so it's love does love exist
objectively
yeah no because it's not grounded in in
the real world and that's the thing
grounding is absolutely crucial but then
you can get that's what I'm trying to
say is we've got these other Concepts we
live by yeah that we think we assume are
objective yes because we often we tell I
love him he loves me but but then then
you get into kind of emergentist
grounding and symbol formation as
Wittgenstein spoke of so love is not
grounded in the physical world but it is
grounded in the language game yeah yeah
agreed and I'm not saying that actually
does make it objective but we desire for
it to be objective like other things we
have like a natural tendency to to want
to know what our world is and it's yeah
let's be honest we live in the world of
the Alps and walls and cameras but
actually more of your time is spent up
dealing with pain and love and guilt and
all these other things that aren't as
objective the problem is then what we're
doing is swimming swimming in a sea of
endless subjectivity it's very hard to
create meaning when that's the case and
I think what art does is it crystallizes
those Illusions to infinite that we've
got these Illusions to the never ending
like redactive ability of things and
gives them sort of like an archetypal
value for a bit do you know it subsumes
it assumes all the unintelligible
thoughts as I said earlier in a desire
to make objective things that can't be
objective yes but two questions on that
first of all why is there such a horizon
of subjective encoding in our language
because I feel that I understand what
you mean when you say love even though
how I experience it and what I interpret
from it completely different unlike the
out you can't point to love you can
point to an example of love yes and then
loved in that like loves in that like
loves in that extract love from all of
them no that mountain is that mountain
yes but then I mean it's very similar to
how we how we come up with categories in
in the first place we do it inductively
so we we take this package of of of
um experiences that we have we bundle it
together in a category and this is an
emergent distributed process so it
happens in our language it happens at
the level of the society and all of
these cognitive categories get bundled
up into these words and we kind of
um arrive on on what we think is a
common understanding of a subjective
category and the problem is it's it's
glitchy it doesn't work right so if I if
I say to you Elon Musk is is Rich right
you seem to understand what I mean right
um we seem to have a common
understanding of what it means to be
rich what a pile of sand is right but if
you start pushing on these Concepts you
don't have to push very far for it to
just blow up into vagueness
so yeah so it has sort of a value at a
certain scale then when you break it
down try to reduce it down to its
components yeah at that point you can't
look at it with the same you can't look
it with the eyes you looked at the
previous scale exactly yeah solution
yeah so I mean on a practical sense when
you say Elon Musk is Rich like you said
I know I could theoretically start
breaking down some stuff there but
there's no point is there oh my whoa I
just yeah that's one of the things that
I would use I mean we all agree that if
you've got 200 and something billion
pounds you're rich he is known as the
richest guy in the world I mean if
you're going to argue that you're gonna
argue everything forever aren't you so
in some respect we just accept that as a
provisional package of information
that's acceptable at that scale because
we're not actually doing the semantics
there we're not breaking down rules
we're not breaking down words Concepts
how does that link to that in the real
world you know this sort of all the
Aristotelian third man thing and where
is the link between the the form the
idea the essence and the example because
that seems to require endless number of
links to keep them remaining in the same
existential field yes
um but we don't do that in the same way
we just accept stuff don't we we have to
accept it because it's like it's like
asking your question are we free do we
have completely do we have free will or
do we have determined determined um
thoughts I mean I've got no idea perhaps
that question the mistake is in the
question itself perhaps like only our
language is glitchy when we get to that
dichotomy we just create a glitch are we
infinite or finite glitch there this is
what um this is what witchenstein
thought isn't it in some respects
whereof we cannot speak thereof we must
pass over in silence there's certain
questions like dead ends illegal Moves
In The Language game yeah they they do
nothing
look we're full of them like you just
said any sentence if broken down a
different scale it leads to similarly
endless if not infinite
um uh infant uh permutations ways of
looking at things aspects yep so there
is we're now saying we continuously
confronted with so many built-in
Infinities built-in sort of lacking of
definitude of actual finite definition
meaning value so where are we getting it
from yeah that is where what we use art
for and actually we're looking at
paintings a second ago there's so many
other forms of art whether it come from
music's probably the purest form because
like as as kirkegaard said in the uh
section of the book either or there was
the immediate stages of the erotic and
he basically said Don Giovanni is the
greatest piece of art not music art
Art's the highest for music is the
highest form and Don Giovanni is the
best and what he was trying to explain
was that When the Music's on you're you
know in a Arena listening to Don
Giovanni your body is literally every
cell of your body is vibrating as it
were with the music experiencing it
there and then it's a specific unique
moment when you listen to it next time
it's the same notes it's a new moment
again yes turn it off the vibration stop
you can then take a pen and write for as
long as you want to describe what you
just experienced yeah you're not
describing what you just experienced
you're describing a verbal a written
description
exactly and he was just trying to show
that those who said the the lack of
effect
um the weakness of words when describing
Sensations and more importantly the r
itself is a moment that happens uniquely
at that period especially when it's
something like music it could be the
same with paintings people say oh I've
looked at it again for the 50th time I
saw something new this time I mean the
desire to go back
the desire to filter now linking back
what I was just trying to say why do we
have a desire could be the meaning thing
like what you just said and we we do
create these okay we're just going to
say like we're just going to say that if
I drop this it will fall the Newton's
correct even though when we look at
science generally we come to that
falsification Theory come to uh yeah
science scientific theory must be
falsifiable yes it must be potentially
one day won't happen it won't be the
case or can be improved upon but we
don't bother questioning whether the
Tank's gonna fall anymore we just accept
Newton's law of gravity there as it were
or rather what it will just fall to the
floor we don't think I'll wait one day
it'll go up so it's not that um there
seems to be apparent meaning
and certain and certain level of
certainty to things although when we try
to understand what that certainty and
meaning comes from or it's composed of
we just get lost and like you say a c of
subjectivity of non-certainty yeah and
there's something about the sea which is
very deep and meaningful so um when I
speak to some AI researchers they say
that the concept of infinity doesn't
exist yes and actually if you want to
have a bright line between different
schools of thought in artificial
intelligence that would be it that would
actually be it so Chomsky is a big
believer in Infinities and his Chomsky
hierarchy draws a bright line between
the recursive languages for example and
the kind the kind of languages that can
be produced by these large language
models and um a lot of people
misunderstand the Chomsky hierarchy it's
not about the set which can be generated
from a computational model it's about
the ability to recognize that a model in
a in a different part of the hierarchy
generated a certain type of of language
but he thinks that that language is
infinite and the way that we process it
is recursive which is the most
sophisticated form of computational
model now folks who are into these large
language models and AI models they I
mean these models don't do recursive
processing they do recurrent processing
so they can't
um recognize or produce recursive
languages which means that they are a
truncated form of of language model
essentially and and he thinks that we
humans when we speak when we think with
this recursive processing we are
traversing an infinite space and when we
experience art we're traversing through
this Infinite Space and that gives us
wonder and the Wonder is because of the
asymmetry when we form abstractions when
we experience art we're traversing this
C of what is basically ontology right
right yeah it is functionally or
practically infinite
but to us yeah the amount of things you
can possibly say
think
yeah I mean Infinities an interesting
one you know there's there's the um the
Hilbert's Hotel
um thought experiment but it's something
which we'll we'll just take take go back
to what we talk about pain or um or love
again yeah okay so take love has the
imagine we sit on 2D plane that we just
do a circle with the word love or
playing or pain in these two concepts
which are already expressed only by
reference to painful or loving scenarios
that's how we generate our idea of what
lava pain is
um it's it's it's finite because not
everything is Love by definition there
are things that aren't love yeah it's
not like oh everything's love no no
there's all pains are examples you know
Joy isn't pain it's toothaches pain and
stuff in your toes pain the difference
they're both painful the you know other
things are so so it's a finite concept
it's only it's got a certain size to
things that can be included but is it
it's about other influent example is are
there a limited number of painful things
no there's an infinite number that's
what I'm saying so you you've got a
limited it's almost like going left
around the globe forever it's a limited
frame work of an infinite time or going
around the Monopoly board you know
theoretically thanks for stopped me
going around the Monopoly board I can go
in Forever well it's only so he's only
held back by the length of time in
existence but then that would be
Infinity that'd be the infinite question
coming back and again anyway
um but there were there are Infinities
everywhere so there's Infinities in the
vakueness of the boundary of the concept
there's also an Infinity in terms of the
way it can be composed with other
Concepts so you can feel pain in
different situations and types of pain
two types of pain together sure sure
that's what I'm trying to yeah so so as
far as like like we're free aren't we we
might be predetermined but not in a way
we can understand hmm we're free it's
like yeah there's a hundreds 100
trillion sales in your body I mean you
can't even come up come up with a uh
formula as it were an algorithm to
explain where we're going to be in three
or four seconds let alone you know where
we're going to be in the future so
therefore we can whether it's free
ordered or predetermined that question
is no longer a relevant one for us so it
I mean we can talk about it uh like in a
um
metaphysical sense for fun uh for like
you know creating the language gives us
more places to play in the playground
it's fun it's it's enjoyable it gives
value and meaning to my life to think
about you know all these various
questions but no I mean you just assume
you're free even people who are even
people who argue it would seem Sam
Harris's who argue for determinism
actors are the actors are there free
yeah just do you see what I mean yeah
yeah and you said something interesting
as well because um because you do a lot
of um uh satire and comedy and a lot of
that is about deliberately playing with
the cognitive apparatus so it's um you
know deliberately creating ambiguity and
kind of forcing the audience in in One
Direction nudging them in One Direction
and then and then ripping you rip the
curtain away you rip the curtain away
exactly yeah oh yeah obviously you've
got the the word it's funny because it's
in some of the greatest satirists my
favorite ones as well with the ones who
are brilliant with words yes you know
and the double the double meanings of
things yes and um oh there's one with a
man said he he he's talking about a lady
so she must go her she has to go Barbara
has to go home now because she's having
the man coming to uh check her um having
the man come to check the attic and
there's nothing she likes more than
being they're having then having a felt
like that either being no then getting
felt laid down in the loft
now I like that because like you said
you're taking off somewhere on a
traditional trajectory it's just a woman
going to meet the guys to come and check
the Loft yeah but then she likes getting
felt laid down in the Loft yeah that's
beautifully you've like just comes in
and takes over and then that's what we
start to laugh don't we we laugh because
I didn't see that one coming yes yes